what's with the jeans take to another
edition of your mom's house podcasts we
are recording and from Silverlake East
Side bitch of Los Angeles this is your
mom's house I am a Tom Segura here with
the lovely christina pazsitzky hello
Christina hello everybody
and um happy almost Christmas to
everyone happy almost Christmas we are
recording the first time on our own
which means that we don't have the
expertise of one red band who would
normally make sure that everything is
perfect but you know what Tom we're not
all about perfect that's right baby
we're about what keeping it real even in
100 well you can't get any more real
than this right now we are recording
like I said on our own we have recently
brand-new purchased microphones that we
just bought from RadioShack and we have
a lot of ground to cover but first of
all it's raining outside it's raining
has been really exciting it's done been
raining it was raining all of yesterday
as well and I actually drove yesterday
from the San Francisco area here yeah
and the entire Drive it rained late
terrible a lot of times when you drive a
long distance you're like oh it's
raining
well I'm sure an hour from now yeah we
got over that shitty weather but like
the whole time 400 miles of rain that's
kind of scary too and you're driving my
car which is a hybrid it's kind of a
pussy car it's not really built for like
Lorraine for terrain and did you really
feel I wasn't
off-roading well I mean you drive
aggressively kind of angry that's not
true get a glass of wine for this
podcast what do you say whatever you
want yeah I don't give a shit yeah okay
hold on why get one okay you're gonna
our listeners yeah why don't you put
that down and don't you get a couple of
glasses so here's the goal have this mom
cast done we'll send it over to Redman
and hopefully he can then work his magic
and put it on the interwebs for us top
everybody how you slept last night and
how you look when you woke up this
morning well here's here's the thing
about this place I love our place we
live in Silver Lake a wonderful home we
have a window unit in the bedroom it's
nicely installed professionally yes and
it's great for when it's hot makes it
not hot but one of the things that
happens is that that metal body of the
air conditioner sticks out and then the
the gutters the rim what is it called
the gutters it's not a good I think it's
hitting on the actual top oh I know the
water drips from from the inner area
onto the the body of the I like regular
I like like a fan noise or like if it's
just generally raining outside but if
you hear I have that mind that can't
like you can block it out yeah I get but
I get used to it and I can't
I cannot what I happens when I hear
things like that just you know I obsess
on that that's why I can't watch TV and
go to bed because if the TV is on I
don't know how to tune it out that's
true because I like the sound of TV I
like it when you stand living room and
you watch TV and then you can fall
asleep but I would hey turn that off
because you need silence I'll be
listening to it so anyways it's her bare
eye I couldn't handle it I had to go out
and get my
my nose cancelling headphone I'm sorry
no no but please explain to these people
they're not noise cancelling have no
babe what they are are headphones that
people wear to listen to music
these are bose noise-canceling like
they're fancy they are and they do block
out sound but you have to understand
people that when my husband puts these
on to sleep he looks like a crazy
homeless person but way that homeless
people when they when they talk to
aliens or they listen to different
frequencies on other planets that's
exactly what my husband fell asleep with
the headphones on just by the way is
more worship makes me look homeless I
already have a whole group of people
that I've never met in the minim Erica
they go hey you're homeless you look
homeless and now we're gonna add to that
yeah that's what you told me this
morning we got we should tell me what
show it's the Jim Rome radio show and my
husband well Jay Bourget I guess fills
in furniture he guest hosts it sometimes
when Jim and then I have is basically a
guest of Jays to be like just have fun
and talk okay and and what do people
notice about your appearance well the
first time I ever did it we always do
photos of that day with the producers
what's the name I'm not gonna forget
their names Jase - and Kyle Brant one
knows I know but I'm just saying I'm
giving those guys props babe yeah they
do care people so and little Alvin and
we all get the fuck out of here so we've
always we take photos and on this
particular in this case we took a photo
and everybody thought that I looked like
the caddy from from from happy gilmore
I guess I'm happy kill more no no Adam I
got a homeless guy to me okay and then
and then so they all just started
it's been a big tweeting thing where
they're like hey you homeless piece of
shit like they're so funny they're very
it's not just hey you almost peed it's
like they say you have to say war is
that what is lingo but basically they're
like Tom Segura uses you know shrimps as
a Bluetooth you know and there's so many
segura using a tailpipe for ear cleaners
or whatever it's endless I wish I had
them all because they're so every time
we did a radio show oh I look forward to
is reading those on Twitter yeah shit on
you it makes me laugh so I should go
fight a little pretty awesome this is
real life we're just talking about that
real people yeah but your boy if you're
bored there I'm not fucking bored it was
just a yawn yawns happen in life even
when you're not bored does gee when you
listen to Howard Stern is he on
sometimes he burps yeah maybe he does
that's not true I'm apologize maybe half
of my husband let me point out one thing
real quick you don't have shit okay
about shit yeah I'm sorry what what
don't I know I'm looking over at our
bookshelf and I got a lot of books that
I've read yeah but I want to be clear
I'm a reader about something you don't
know shit about shit and you never have
about shit yeah real mature yeah anyways
alright crazy homeless so you woke up
with your crazy headphones on yeah I did
you got your bear fur cut you got your
hair cut
where what's the name of the salon I
don't want to talk about it but I got my
hair cut
it looks clean look great very handsome
I got it cut for baby ages cuz birthday
which is coming up on the 25th and I
want to look good and just taking care
of last day shit you know what I really
fucking hate and everyone I know I feel
like you're finally coming on board not
you're finally you're on board I feel
like other people are finally coming on
board
well that is the fucking concept of hey
we're all adults now let's stop with the
with we're gonna get presents for every
poppin and this is I know it's partially
influenced by you know by money I mean
I'm sure if I was a multi-millionaire
like everybody good but even even if
that were the case I still feel like you
know what we're over 30 yeah why don't
we dial it back on the the obligatory
yeah everybody gets to get you don't get
a gift yeah we're we're like you get any
when you get gifts you get gifts when
you're a kid because it's fucking
awesome and you're like in it and you're
supposed to surprise or even like on
birthdays like when you're a kid and you
turn fucking six everybody gets you a
birthday present is your kid and like
you know that's what you're supposed to
do is get the kid something it makes you
know why because a kid can't go out and
get himself shit that's right if you if
you want you know a Snoopy sno-cone
machine and you're five well guess what
you have to wait all year yeah until
Santa brings it or you beg but right
because you you don't have the ability
to get in your car and go out and
fucking get it because you can't drive
and walk into places you don't have cash
or credit card or anything yeah but like
now it's like you know I didn't feel
where when it's like one like I got one
of my sisters or or like even you know a
cousin or a friend just like hey you
know what I need I really need these uh
these these new shoes to go running and
it's like really go fucking buy them how
old are you yeah you're old enough to
buy your own shit well you know when
people ask me what do you want for
Christmas
well nothing I'm fucking 34 years old I
can go on and buy myself yeah well I'll
tell people get me something little and
stupid you know but that's for an
insistent what am i what am I really
gonna ask for who I really need I'd like
a new fucking iPad yeah that's eight
hundred dollars go go get me an iPad ago
give me anything I don't need anything
my sister one of my sister's is like
what do you want
and I just go boxers yeah yeah I mean
like what am I gonna ask you for the
shit that I fucking
I really want badly we'd like an Italian
steam-driven espresso machine cuz they
best be fresh it's like they've asked me
for shit that's like wow you know
there's jewelry from this one like
jewelry take your goddamn mind right now
it's ridiculous what do i sisters sent
me an email with a breakdown with shit
she wanted but okay but to her credit
that is useful when we cuz we've
established rules this year like you
don't have to buy it for everybody just
like a select few know but that's
helpful because then you don't have to
like go through the bullshit was the
deal there's gonna be a lot of people at
my parents house to see her including us
yeah Christmas so every so many people
are gonna be there that the the
announcement went out the fucking the
the APB went out for everybody that hey
don't go out and buy presents for
everyone I did but the mic didn't pick
it up I picked it up I know it's coming
I just I hope you stew in your own shit
I'm doing it right now
it smells you are such an animal but
here's the thing
so I was told I was told don't worry
about everybody you know he should worry
about yeah they told me to worry about
my cousin Brian right my cousin Brian
because they're like that's you know
that'll be your guy you just worry about
him cuz you know what I said great I
called Brian you know what he said let's
just go out to dinner because that's
fuckin because he's a fucking adult yeah
and then yeah like Vegas what I got I
made the phone call just talk to one of
my sisters about whatever she's like oh
so you know I got you something and I go
what the I thought the deal was you just
buy for one part you buy for one of the
other cousins so what do you want to get
me that's ones the next now here comes
more money no can I tell you something I
don't give a fuck I don't expect
anything from anybody and guess what I'm
not giving anything to anybody and they
know this about me okay yeah can I tell
you my biggest pet peeve I just had a
dear friend of mine I love her very much
text message
me hey when can I come over and drop off
your Christmas gift now it's a very nice
gesture but I don't want the fucking
gift because I didn't buy anything for
her right and now I'm gonna feel like a
turd because she comes over here with
again after I've told her for years
please don't buy me shit right and now I
feel like the asshole cuz I don't have
stuff for people you know you should do
just get people like cards and like a
candy cane you know what I mean like
something stupid and little not not a
fucking again yeah millionaires for
God's sake it's it's really was what
when you start thinking about like the
money adding up and you're like holy
shit I'm spending fucking hundreds of
dollars just so that like just so I
don't look like an asshole warning or
whatever like for a grown up you should
be happy with like a little piece of
candy or I had all the fucking there's
the backpedaling in my household because
like even after that was established my
mom was talking to my mother and she
goes well you got you know you got to
get something for like I thought we just
said that fucking what she's just like
you know you will make sure you have
something for like one of your this
sister and like you know then just like
you know just make sure you have some I
know that this aunts gonna have
something for you like why are you
fucking telling me that like I don't
want to have to buy fucking you and I
are traveling so we're what are we gonna
do pack another suitcase full of shit
just a drag to Florida that's insane
and look you and I travel for a living
or not even home long enough to go
shopping just sound like we're not
normal oh my god I wanted to have one
get picked up on the audio I can't
believe you let me just describe oh my
god I'm gonna throw up babe it smells
like like those Japanese dumplings we
had babe oh I like that you could use
one marriage
are you you're pushing away with oh my
god what did you shoot today I think so
did you shit this morning I think I did
I don't remember you shitting this
morning I do I remember you tried to
shit just a while ago and I know I said
earlier it's small town it smells like
somebody shit no it smells like soshould
trapped in there that needs to come out
it does
god damn you who else would love you
you're such a fucking animal
alright alright Oh remember last night
we were watching The Millionaire
Matchmaker and Judith Regan was on it
and Tommy turns to me and he goes I
could tell like its wholly impressed
Judith Regan I think she would like you
she would love me and I was like yeah
she's not gonna tolerate your farts I
think I would charm writing in today
what if you get a chance to watch with
ray shall good friends she said some
Judah Jews like I want someone that
makes me laugh yeah so paddy gets the
brilliant idea had to go to Caroline's
and have like a fuck she was basically
Last Comic Standing audition I was so
embarrassed but it was for dating and it
was so horrifying to watch yeah well as
but I mean even the last comic auditions
are because that's that's not the way to
audition comics to have like three
people sit at a table and be like well
if you're funny make is like that's a
horrible prospect but anyways she she
just has guys that are I guess
age-appropriate for Judith which is like
I guess 40 and up well first of all it's
preface that by saying if you don't know
who Judith Regan is she's a very famous
publisher and she published like Howard
Stern's biography autobiography
Jenna Jameson's I mean she's a very
respected very serious exemption right
she's very very successful woman but
then she has these like these guys
like embarrassing it was so embarrassing
and then patty chose a couple and wait
remember the dinner and there at dinner
and then there and Judith was like you
know gracious enough so like yeah I mean
I don't know how much if she really
enjoyed her if she was just being like
all right no she I think she enjoyed it
give those guys we're actually running
their shitty bits what about when you
fly to Australia that's really good
23 hours whoa okay so why don't they
just paid a plane that hovers for 12
hours and let us will you come to me get
the fuck out of here man that's another
guy like that of course yeah
but they're not comics they're usually
open yeah so usually guys that run like
like when you're on the road and they'll
be like who's like you know the thing is
and you're like are you a man are you
running your ship I mean yeah like I
mean I even like I did a really small
show in San Francisco last week and I
saw that there were one of those shows
that like 15 people goes to so some of
the people in the audience are comics at
that performed so when you get on stage
you you remember that you go like I'm
not going to address these these guys
that I saw before right so like another
part during the show when I'm up there
I'm talking to a guy who I didn't see
perform but then it occurs to me like a
few minutes in just to make sure like
after that I go hey man you're not a
comic right and he was like what I go
you're not a comic and he goes no not I
go okay cuz if you were I wouldn't like
I wouldn't keep going to you for shit
like I wouldn't ask you right yeah I'm
not gonna fucking work it out with
another comic so but it's like sometimes
you go on the road and like the guys I
don't know the local guys like they
start to do to do their fucking shit and
they try to leave it into conversation
worse you're like yeah dude I know what
you're doing nobody does that
like nobody were friends with likes your
no like friends never like you just say
to someone hey is this funny I'm sorry
I'm like stepping on nothing yeah you'd
never do that that's like for older I'm
sorry I'm putting my I had these
cvs/pharmacy house slippers that I just
replaced with proper house slippers and
I just put my house slippers our podcast
recording device very rudely I apologize
it wasn't professional Sweethearts for
sure those blackberries yeah wait yeah
so and then she oh I just told you that
I think that Regan would be totally into
me
oh that's right and then and I agree
with you because you're very you're very
interesting you're very intelligent yeah
and very dynamic if I could choose a
word can I tell you something though is
that you do have a lot of hair and
you're very farty you have a lot of gas
and a lot of burps and farts and a lot
of dumps I feel like that's an unfair
characterization that's a big word thank
you
I think she would have to enjoy toilet
shit the way that I do whatever anyways
yeah so that was something that happened
and then well let's see like this week a
couple of things getting ready for
Christmas I was up in Northern
California this week actually oh I
should mention this last week you did
the podcast cast the mob cast with Ari I
believe with our who admitted by the way
yeah that he lost his virginity at the
age of 23
that's insane and then his parents were
Orthodox well didn't admit that no he
but I think that that was a big reason
for him yeah he was hardcore to the
floor like he was he was super Jew
he wasn't he he still looks very jewy
yeah the look is definitely there but he
she's Hispanic he he definitely is more
than made up for that virginity lasting
so long Wow
but while you guys were fucking around
doing your mom cast I was in Minneapolis
Minnesota where a little thing called a
blizzard came through and I don't know
if you saw the footage of the Metrodome
collapsing but I was there I was there
all week and Friday night we got the
warning we did our two shows Friday
night and the news at first the news was
we're gonna get six inches and everybody
was like whatever and then all of a
sudden out of nowhere they're like no
we're not we're not gonna get six inches
we're gonna get we're gonna get two feet
yeah and everybody was like yeah
everywhere the club goes believe me they
say this shit all the time like you have
no idea the storm that's coming and it
never happened so I was like all right
anyways the snow started to come down
Friday night so when I walked back to
the hotel from the club it's snowing
yeah and you're like all right cool like
it's gonna snow for a while I wake up
the next morning there's a foot of snow
on the ground and it doesn't stop all
day so I text my buddy Josh at Acme
comedy club ain't gonna like Josh what's
the deal for the night we're not doing a
show are we he goes oh yeah we're doing
a show what do you mean we're doing is
showing is we're doing a show I call
them a couple hours later and I go well
look man at this point by the way it is
not stopped snowing in 24 hours what the
fuck is coming out right so it's I call
them when I go are we really gonna do a
show we have reservations the places up
that we're doing a show I go okay now I
look out the window and there's 16 to 18
inches of snow on the ground like
there's cars that are like like they're
you know they're blanketed into their
spot all right so I'm looking all I see
is snow and I go well look man that the
the clubs like a five minute walk from
the hotel I go you know it's not even
paths to walk the Reg oh well can you
just can you send a car
pick me outside to walk in this shit
because Tom we we can't drive in this
shit man
motherfucker like you want me to walk we
can't yeah how we gonna get a car out of
the spot and I go how am I supposed to
walk there well how are people supposed
to drive the whole thing doesn't make
sense
so I dry I go whatever I walk I hike
through the fucking Himalayas I get to
the club he's like well the good news is
we cancelled the second show we still
the first show first show ended up being
we had by the way here's the only part I
wish you didn't tell me because by the
way I never want to know this if this is
the truth both shows were sold out yeah
they were both sold out and then he goes
but now there's 40 people why did you so
40 people are there in a bizarre like
just unexpected twist I ended up having
more fun at the 40 per person show
during the blizzard yeah they were just
because obviously they really wanted to
be there because they came out in a
blizzard yeah and it was the most fun
but then after the show I go you know
that was crazy and the two managers work
and go that was a stupid thing we ever
did was I was like it's fucking it's
dangerous like people can die yeah it's
silly and especially because they're
drinking during the show yeah we're
gonna get their hammers but I mean
there's people there's staff that
couldn't make it to the club cuz it
costs more to operate the club that
night their reasonings they do get to
say hey you know what yeah nothing shuts
down Acme comedy club can I tell you
though I honest I think we've discussed
this before and normal non podcast life
that uh
sometimes a 40-person or even like a ten
person show if there's good people it's
better than like a 500 or whatever huge
venue I don't I like small shows oh yeah
like a small intimate thing and you can
just kind of bullshit and tell stories
and feel like you're actually connecting
with humans that's what happened it was
there was a much bigger like on the big
shows like if it had been sold out it's
there's a there's a higher energy level
like you put something out and the
energy that you get back yeah it's much
greater yeah yeah you know the laughs
are louder just there's more excitement
it's like when you go to a party and
there's three other people at the party
there's there's an energy to it right
like wow it's it's it's live but if you
go to a ten person like house dinner
party yeah you're gonna connect with
each person that's kind of the
equivalent I think over the shows like
you make connections with the people oh
yeah but so it's just really like what
do you what do you feel like that night
what do you want you know yeah
but anyways so I almost didn't get out
of there
I almost got stuck in the in the
blizzard like I almost that's right
leave then I came back and I went to
Northern California San Francisco and I
did this room called Club deluxe which
is on Haight Street and I was followed
that up with a night at the San Jose
improv which was really fun always fun
there the purple onion the legendary
purple onion and ended it with Tommy T's
bang bang bang Pleasanton California it
was a fun little run but while I was
doing that you were in he went to ATL
snowing you did its no no I just I just
pictured it being like Song of the South
or people just fan themselves and like
Brer Rabbit sure yeah I had no idea they
just drink sweet tea and it was yeah it
was so cold I was there with Sarah Tiana
I was a good friend of mine it's really
fun I mean the shows are okay it was
like a suburb for the fine
where were you at that funny forum yeah
it's like a funny farm is yeah it's all
well let's be clear it's it's not just
because I'm sure it's not just in a
suburb its
racecar track that's right that's in the
suburbs it literally the comedy club is
next to it's in an arcade yeah so you
can hear the sound of games being played
and here's the thing the first time
I played that Club yeah I went with the
the guy that runs it he picked me up
from the hotel and then parked and I go
what what is this where are we he goes
we're at the club cuz it says like Mario
Andretti yeah but where's the club and
he goes inside and I go oh there's not a
sign there and he goes yeah I know
Howard Howard numbers he was like now
they're a little low I know do you think
I fuckin design help that so people
would know he's like well actually there
is a sign and there was a sign but the
sign was like by some trees like hung
over but not on the front of the
building like if you walk to the front
of the building it doesn't say comedy no
you have no reason to believe that
there's anything funny going on remotely
in that building you know and you have
reason to believe there's racecars yeah
because it tells you there's a lot of
race car advertising skee-ball plenty of
that you play a video game and I did
race I actually raced those cars fun
right I was so terrified I was terrible
at it because I had a few to drink yeah
and I was like mortified it was very bad
at it they go fast right yeah I don't
you know look man I'm not a thrill
seeker in life I'm uh I'm very scared of
life I'm full of anxiety where why are
you scared of life because I you know
you know I'm in therapy that's okay my
childhood but I just I just I'm not one
of these people that needs to like I
don't need to fucking jump on a bungee
jump or skydive to feel alive I feel
like life is scary enough for me so I'm
with you yeah like adding like I don't
understand when people run marathons
like really isn't that isn't life hard
enough you have to add the fucking extra
thing of a marathon I totally I I do
feel the to the sort of the old guy
syndrome of like you have done that
maybe 10 15 years ago like you're all
you're not no no I'm saying with that
mentality yeah like what someone's like
hey do you want to jump off this thing
I'd be like maybe 10 years ago I would
but like at this point I don't feel I
don't go like I need that rush you know
I agree but I feel like our occupation
our occupations rather it's so uncertain
like our day-to-day existence is so
uncertain as it is like you don't know
how your jobs gonna go on any given
night so you don't even know what you're
what you're if you're gonna have work
yeah
next month so you know I'm on pins and
needles as it is sure why should I talk
about what I did last this week so I
auditioned for this movie part yeah
about a week ago
Mickey taught you and signed like a
nondisclosure or anything right no okay
if there's a trailer office movie okay
I'm the knowledge the story it's not
Wikipedia - yeah okay so I go in to
audition for this part this it's like a
sketch comedy movie it's called the
underground comedy movie and I go in I
auditioned for like the part of like
some 20 year old hot librarian which I'm
clearly not you know whatever and I look
at the guy the director and I'm like
director looks like the ShamWow guy but
that guy's dead it can't be him I do the
audition it goes fine whatever and I
leave and I text my friend who set me up
with it and he goes yeah no that was a
ShamWow guy I'm like you gotta be
fucking kidding me yeah I mean well
should be pointed out right now that
yeah you had him confused for really
amazing a different pitch man who is
dead right so you were right that
there's a dead guy yeah but this guy's
so if you read the story so he it's a
fascinating if you Wikipedia this guy
his name is Vince offer and he
essentially started peddling the ShamWow
to fund this movie that he made 10 years
ago called the underground comedy movie
he was a comic right and he wrote these
sketches with him and like Bobby Lee and
whatever and he made the movie for like
no money and it didn't do so well in the
box office but then he had this great
idea of marketing it on direct response
television and so he would like sell
DVDs on dr and he sold a lot he's sold
like 50,000 copies crazy yeah and so now
he's kind of like remaking this movie
was also 10 years later he also had from
amenda success ShamWow slap low right so
he thought you know he thought to
himself well if I can market this movie
this way surely I can sell a ShamWow and
fund another project so he started
selling the ShamWow swap meets and then
he did the same thing on direct response
television and he's a multi-millionaire
all right so now sorry I'm writing on
this guy's movie right so you audition
so you didn't get the part in the
audition for but you were so funny and
you're so talented
well I can brag though we're so funny
then that they were like I'd like to
have you come in and write and consult
when we're actually shooting the ended
of getting writing the resulting my work
on on the actual opportunity or the film
is so cool which has some big names in
it - yeah he's managed like like Adrien
Brody is in it and Michelle Rodriguez
and Rob Schneider and it's good I think
it's gonna be really Lindsay Lohan's in
it for God's sake I mean he's really
doing it right I think it's gonna be
really cool did you meet Lindsay you
didn't mention it no now that's a
different she already did her Adrienne
no he's an Oscar winner I got to meet
Rob Schneider he's pretty cool cool guy
right yes it was very nice
he's very nice yeah he's very talented
yeah actually pretty funny was cool it
was cool to watch somebody that's
actually like and Vince is the next
super nice guy dude guys play swimming
and then Hollywood a lot of people are
d-bags
yeah but Vince really is one of the
nicest people on the planet yeah just
genuinely nice and that really helps
that's great because you're working yeah
that's excellent
yeah that's a neat it's been an
interesting week and then today you
won't tell them what happened today what
do you mean what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean babe what in the
car no no no okay no it's
No all right I was gonna tell story but
I guess that well well I mean now you
got to tell some personal story lying
because because now you're like you're
dancing up and around to it all right
you don't know I like to share but I
just feel like me too much
I think so then we will say this that we
saw the movie Black Swan well that's
what I was gonna get to oh okay no it's
fine we did all right well now there's
like a big seat we're gonna have to go
back to this secret we'll go back to
lately some other time I guess we we did
we went to see well let's point Ford
this out we'll get to this all right the
there's a lot of times there are
Hollywood has mastered making trailers
that I think like how many times have
you seen a trailer we like that looks
fucking awesome or that looks cooler
like I mean trailers are an art in and
of themselves you know I mean like
cutting a trailer yeah for a film
Oh break right but have you ever seen
those things where they remix the
trailers like they'll make the shining
into like a family comedy based on just
the music and the rieta ting of the
trailer do you know I haven't seen that
those trailer remixes no they're
fantastic I haven't seen that but I
think of how many I mean like I actually
really enjoy trailers like I like
watching trailers for films I love it
and it's amazing like it's amazing how
it can go either way and and how how you
almost basically can't trust it but you
can't trust it either way I mean you can
see a trailer for a movie that you're
like god that looks terrible and if it's
a comedy and the trailer looks god-awful
there's a good chance that's a
piece-of-shit film to begin you know if
they can't show you any funny comedy
that's slang I think I thought I finally
you can get misled more
and because I feel like if you're not
laughing in that trailer it's supposed
to be really funny there's a good chance
of stuff well like I can tell you right
now the new Fockers movie yeah thumbs
down yeah yeah totally yeah yeah there's
a lot there's so much that's wrong with
that this act
yeah like beginning with the title and
the creation of that you know but even
the billboards sometimes you go oh
that's gonna suck oh yeah you see it
you're like this is shit yeah but then
there's a but this movie I mean you know
I know it's totally subjective but I saw
the trailer for Black Swan I think I saw
it first with you we were at a different
movie but it's cut with a lot of like
just hard edits and you see that like
you know she doesn't know what she's
seeing is it real and and and you know
it's like some you know there's shit
like growing on her back and it looked
like a really like intense psychological
thriller which when those are well done
when it's well-made it's like my
favorite type of movies yeah I love
watching those movies so I saw that
trailer and I was like I mean I haven't
gone to like I watch a lot of movies but
I don't go that often to the movies that
was one where I was like I want to go to
the theater and see this movie yeah
looks fucking sick I thought I thought
the trailer sold that film as like this
is going to blow your fucking mom right
and that guy Kundalini 70 showgirl yeah
yeah and that French guy with the big
nose
what's week where's your phone is your
phone right there yeah maybe that way
you can I see it yeah yeah he said oh
yeah sorry
vincent cassell yeah i think is his name
there was a and it looks kind of gothy
and like it was a very it was very like
all this movie's gonna fog employer
yeah there was just everything about
that trailer wish we had it blew your
mind up Holly I would plug it into here
right now yeah anyways yeah you can
oh and Darren Aronofsky that's the
director's name right yes psi I looked
at the reviews and the critics are all
like saying this is the greatest darkest
thriller of all time get the fuck out of
here it's got nothing but rave reviews
Aronofsky's defense he made requiem for
a dream I didn't like that I gotta be
honest with you okay fucking depressing
City I don't want to watch heroine
movies anymore I'm over it
Trainspotting was gray made pie okay
he made the wrestler that was great
no that was depressing you shit - super
impressive but super was amazing yeah
yeah the fountain I remember that Cena
but pretty much what the dude is telling
you is I'm fucking solid and this and he
he wrote the fountain requiem for a
dream high and a film called below
anyways solid this guy's got a solid
resume I have never in my movie going
experience Ben it's not that the movie
was so fucking bad but I've never been
so let down like from what my ex might
that's the bad thing about I guess you
know trailers and all that shit in
previews and Buzz is like my
expectations for this movie were so high
and I really was like are you fucking
kidding me yeah and then to hear that so
many people love this movie I don't know
what the fuck they saw that I didn't see
nothing about the movie like surprised
me no not there was no like no way kind
of moment there was no intense like
shocking like discovery I mean every
oh the main thing the thing that we
talked about afterwards was I didn't
even lean over and say to you but thirty
minutes in I wanted to go has anything
happened in this movie because nothing
in the movie like develop now there's no
fucking story happening
well the story the story is is there but
it's already like unleashed in the first
thirty minutes of film you already know
what's happening what's gonna happen but
scene just seems like every rehearsal
scene is the same every scene with mommy
is the same every scene like every
fucking thing about that movie and then
you're like like you know there's
feathers growing out of her and you're
like alright so she's just cool right
you're like but I want it like that's
supposed to for me like something like
that's like holy shit yeah what's gonna
be the thing you know like it's gonna
turn into what's the bigger revelation
like she's turning into an animal okay
into an actual Swan
but I didn't like and I did feel there's
a lot of gratuitous masturbation and it
felt like Natalie Portman was having her
couch rub Oh another thing that's weird
and it's a very weird thing I never
really thought about this before was
like misplaced or how do you correctly
place your comedic relief in these poets
there's no comedic relief but there were
some things that were like like clearly
the time I mean work with okay here's a
sport spoiler alert
we're gonna go into some details right
here but like clearly when remember like
the night after she partied with Mila
and Mila was like oh did you have like a
lesbian fantasy about me yeah oh my god
how was it that was supposed to be
comedic that was supposed to be funny
and she left but there was some other
times remember like when I remember and
then there's people who are like
laughing really hard we were like what
can we tell the scene yeah
so there's a scene spoiler alert do not
listen if you don't want to hear there's
a scene where Natalie Portman tries to
rub one out by herself
and she's in her room and it's a very
it's so funny because female
masturbation scenes to me always come
across as very dramatic and overly you
know she's intensely flowery yeah like I
have to say that at least from what I've
happened in my own life it's never as
flowery and beautiful as when Natalie
Portman's yours is like double-headed
standing over me baby that's not a
masturbation I'm sorry no they watch me
that's the fantasy I have the Mexican
gardener fantasy what are you doing in
there so anyway so there's a scene and
she's you know furiously masturbating
and then she looks over and sees her
mother sleeping in the chair right her
and it's supposed to be a funny the
mother well no so I don't know it's
supposed to be funny I didn't think that
people laughing right but I'm saying I
don't I don't think his intention with
that scene was like here's communica
leaf well I think it was because
Natalie's reaction to seeing the mother
wasn't of Whore it was like 'omg mom
like it was more like God I thought she
then took that like she know that was
humor because people laughed no but not
everybody left there was it like a group
that laughs no our side didn't laugh
because we were the voice of reason but
then there was there no people were
laughing no people I'm not the baby the
people were laughing horrifying but I
thought the intention of that was
remember she went to masturbate she's
she's starting to lose control that was
the whole thing was like that loose she
masturbated and then she looked over saw
her mother and mother had fallen asleep
the you know the what it was showing you
was that the mother had fallen asleep in
the room like all night she fell asleep
in the chair so she was there in the
morning still and I thought she was
horrified and covered herself up like
she got under the sheet right but I
didn't see that as like haha funny that
is no because her reaction
the reaction that she chose to give was
comedic it was it was like a surprise
like it was more of like a light
reaction because in reality if you saw
that you would be a bit mortified more
to fussing she was more of like OMG my
mum Sarah jerking off but also the point
that seeing I think was to to show you
how controlling the mother was and how
well yeah prohibiting and present of
course but there's so there's just so
much about this film that was so
disappointing to me to me personally I'm
not going to to go out and say like like
what a shit movie but it was like it was
to me it was wildly disappointing in
what you're so upset
I'm so so mad when when the lights came
up he was yelling at the other patrons I
did there were at least 70 people in the
theater and I stood up and I said who
like that and then he'll be like don't
start asking and there was something we
read there like people around the
country are like what a great like
they're applauding oh boy can I tell you
something thought that movie 127 hours
about a guy getting his arm stuck in a
rock was a thousand times more
suspenseful and a thousand you already
knew that and I tell you what when that
guy cut his fucking arm off everybody's
asshole puckered at the same time it was
a wonderful moment yeah and and you're
so emotional for him and I felt more
watching that movie than I did you know
Natalie Portman I love Natalie Portman
she's great actors are great there is so
much well I guess the the big thing is
in the end this movie the movie
essentially mirrored that what I guess
what they attempted was for the movie to
mirror the story of the ballet right
let's give it that is that it was
visually very beautiful yeah the girls
are beautiful and the story
it did yes mirror the swan lake ballet
right but that wasn't like it wasn't
shocking or surprising like it was such
a natural build that like you saw it
coming yeah but I will say you know on
the other hand it was very intriguing to
see like kind of about the ballet world
and to see how difficult it is it's
hardcore and it's so crazy how athletic
these girls are and you know the bleed
Ito's and all that shit you just oh my
god this is not glamorous that actor
Vincent Cassell I think he's great
that guy could watch take a dump I can
watch him day yeah he's a great actor
yeah I think Dave Chappelle I can watch
take a shit to Dave Chappelle I think
Dave Chappelle is so interesting yeah
yeah vincent cassell
yeah he's a really good actor
the French are so great you know who
else I love that Audrey tattoo that
though that doll she's great yeah so
yeah Black Swan aesthetically pleasing
story's a little lacking I think I want
to see Tron man that thing's gonna be
dope yeah there's a lot of stuff coming
out man Tron if you grew up in like the
1980s Tron is one of those like just
fundamental fucking films it was the
first movie that I saw as a kid I never
saw you miss it cause you were born
three years too late yeah but in like
1980 I was four years old and it just
blew my mind because I was like the
first movie was like there was Star Wars
then there was like the special effects
of Tron yeah I can't wait to see that
one well what is a Yogi Bear Yogi Bear
no I can't believe I you know I just I
guess when the when those types of
movies come out on me I'm like it's just
not surprising it's expected there's
actual but there's there's hatred like
on Twitter about Yogi Bear
people are like fired up that they're
making this movie I don't know I don't
know I just have been reading like great
tweets of like way to fucking dust off
this piece of shit Smurf size-12 Smurfs
Smurfs go to Chicago or something tell
us first go to new you know Smurfs
property is owned by this Belgian
company so for years they never released
the rights why I don't know they were
weird about it I used to work in
animation for years and I would always
ask I worked for a company called Duke
entertainment they did inspector gadget
and Shortcake and they were forever
trying to get the rights to Smurfs yeah
but that company wouldn't release it
that was a huge that was the first
cartoon to ever incorporate merchandise
I mean you could buy all those shitty
little Smurfs yeah that literally was
like one of the first cartoons to come
up with that idea of like toys to go
with it we had we had sushi tonight oh
we're gonna have sake with it we throw
it down - we always have the problem of
ordering too much because when you look
at like if you just look at like the
regular sushi pieces you're like yeah I
have one of these and two of these are
three right but then you're like so
that's warm up and then you go I guess
we gotta worry some other stuff yeah I
always ordered too much always we took
we took it down oh we're fucking around
so here's the deal it's uh it's just a
few days away Christmas time is there's
a week from today no in Africa if it's
Christmas time at all they don't know I
think they know because they probably
get a lot more charitable donations this
one your ad song do they know it's
Christmas
No yeah that shitty fucking it was feet
that was like the USA for Africa they
use that and then bono I think like
think this year thank God it's them
there won't be snow in Africa it's like
really hate Bono
I hate that guys so much he really that
guy really hard on I always think about
guys like that and I go like just move
the fucking Africa like he's always on
the African thing look I think is great
to be charitable yeah the way he I think
he's really done a lot I mean the guys
look oh yeah he's donated incredible
amounts of time I'm sure money resources
to to better the world in particularly
but yeah it's like boner we get it like
but they don't have hard-ons for Africa
like Angelina Jolie
and and you know I tell you something
I've been to Africa okay I didn't I've
done USO tours in Djibouti and Ethiopia
it's a shitty fucking place
okay Africa I feel bad for them mmm-hmm
there is it would be a Herculean effort
to fix that country well yeah it is it
is so beyond repair it is so beyond my
hearing underneath that just fuck it
like leave it alone yeah I'm hearing you
know what Africa go wait 2010 is let
Africa go let it go guys look Africa
let it go I will say this that is such
an amazing let it go let's stop trying
to help the people of Africa forget
Africa here's why I've been there either
yes I've been there I will tell you what
they do have in Ethiopia hot beautiful
African women I'm telling you I met I
saw women in the airport that made Iman
look like a pile of shit made her look
like yesterday's gorgeous faces I mean I
it's unbelievable and other than that
you know it's it's really depressing
there's there's kids playing soccer and
garbage heaps and it's such a fucking
bummer but you realize at that level of
poverty I mean in all seriousness is not
it's not just something that exists in
Africa no I mean a lot of Central and
South America oh yeah I mean I've been
in the slums of Peru like where it's
horrifyingly poor I've seen it in Costa
Rica I've seen it and in a number of
places where you see like the hillsides
covered also yeah but it's like Africa
first of all when I was there in August
of last sort of like oh nine it was
literally a hundred forty wait so was
decreasing it's gonna snow in Africa
this Christmas yeah we're gonna let it
go we're a hundred forty degrees in
August it was hot as balls
there's no agriculture there's no water
I'm saying at least in Latin America
there's shanty towns but Africa's I mean
when I saw it for fun was just like and
another thing too these fucking
celebrities like Angelina Jolie she made
her money in America she made her money
in in good old US of A so you know a
bitch why don't you adopt some some
American black kids you love black kids
so much why don't you adopt or even
brown ones anybody how about America
take over the country that made you and
your father very wealthy you know
and I get that she does work but yeah I
do think it's cool to help out
everywhere but I agree with you that
there's a lot of fucked up places and
people in the United States and yeah
there's nothing wrong with trying to
like better your own community
I'm not against helping Africa or
anywhere man oh you want to let it go
but I do feel like like for as far as
like people that insist on adopting
abroad it's like there's a lot of
incredibly poor you know kids need homes
I'm sure they'd love to live with you
know Brad Pitt yeah I would
thirty-four-year-old
white woman I think they would yeah I
think as far as the levels of poverty
yeah the the levels of poverty that you
can find in in the poorest places in
South America or as bad as anywhere in
the world
Wow yeah there might be more like
percentage-wise more but like the the
slums are thus like there's no it's not
like all these Islam's over here like
the slums of Brazil and Peru and Bolivia
and Colombia are the slums of you know
Somalia
like they're just their slums there's
cardboard boxes and people yeah I was
right there and you literally have
people that go around gunning down women
and children yeah that happens that
happens in South America the thing that
separates Africa that really makes it
much like that makes the situation know
is is HIV that's a tremendous problem
there's a there's a there's countries
Botswana has a one in four hiv-positive
right
25 percent of the population is HIV
positive Wow now on that note I want you
guys all have a very Merry Christmas
I know it's horrifying it's horrible
it's horrifying I was just saying that
that's something that is more unique to
Africa
not the poverty I know we should talk
about things that people can't buy
therefore I do what I was gonna say was
is that how much of your life is based
on luck and where you're born in the
world and and I think about that quite
often action I do have a thought quite a
bit how lucky you are just to be born I
breathe you know what you know when that
thought is best to have to when you're
down on yourself like when you're like
yes I wish I had this and I wish I had
that yes I wish I'd gotten this gig and
I wish I was that's doing this and then
you go like man I also love that there
aren't fucking mines on the way it was
when I walked to the grocery store there
aren't landmines and that every other
person I know isn't dead at like 21 oh
yeah you know you have the 30 bucks or
whatever to go down to the Grove and
then watch Black Swan yeah hate it come
home and do a bitchy podcast yeah like
all this shit yeah and this is like yeah
it's incorrect I'm when you go like
really it's like yeah when you're on
when you're having like a great thing
where you're just like amazed you
obviously have your appreciation for
your situation you know when you have
like I can't believe I just got to do
this
amazing and you're thankful but it's
when you're doing something that's
completely whatever or you're
complaining about your situation that
you go holy fuck I'm such a piece of
shit yeah I'm so lucky that I was born
here and then I wasn't born in the
fucking Sudan and that I've never I've
never ever experienced famine and
drought
I won't ever experience you know like
like why are you separating me from my
mother like all that crazy third-world
shit yeah I mean how much and then you
think about what would some of those
people accomplish if they were born in
our situations because inevitably some
of them would be amazing contributors
yeah you know I'm saying if there are
people that are born into fucking just
the worst situation ever
and they'll never get to contribute
because they can't because their whole
life will be based on just trying to
stay alive and when you're just trying
to stay alive you don't really get to
work out other things but there's
probably there are I'm sure amazing
people that are born into these
horrifying situations which I just
realized we have essentially come full
circle full circle and given reason why
to adopt let's start a website called
but on the other hand I agreed struggle
makes you a lot more interesting number
one and that we were watching that
Gwyneth Paltrow fucking bullshit trailer
where she's a kind a soulful country
singer with a heart you know give me a
break when Paltrow eat nothing but still
that goes to the trailer where you can
go you watch the trailer you know I
don't but I tell you this right now
there are a hundred million people in
the United States just some of that
trailer and you know we do with those
people send them to fucking Africa let
it go and we decimate that let him go
that movie looks really terrible of
course it looks but see the thing is
that people that have shit live shit up
brings and they do come to this country
they often
become very successful yeah yeah it's
true those the people that are really
interesting and how many how many rich
kids have you grown up with that I've
done absolutely nothing with their lives
well that was the other that was the
other time that I thought about that a
lot was knowing a lot of rich kids
growing up and especially there was like
you know there's you get to see the full
spectrum of people in within every like
you know demo hit the like there's
there's rich kid like you shouldn't like
did like strongly dislike a kid because
he's born in a situation but I met a lot
of well I met a lot of rich people
entitled rich kids who I always just
wanted to go like you you've done that
nothing except be born like you know I
mean like oh yeah you were just born and
you have made zero contribution and I
know a number of them that are grown now
that I'm like are you just you're not
gonna do anything at all in life like
you just you don't have because you're a
human you don't want a sense of
accomplishment in life no I personally
do but then on the other hand my natural
if someone like my natural inclination
is to be very lazy mmm-hmm necessity is
the only reason I work as hard as I do
at anything if i if i were to be raised
with a lot of money
I wouldn't fuckin do anything I would
travel so it's good that you I would do
heroin I would have sex with millions of
strangers
wait money yeah because if you got AIDS
or STDs you just pay somebody to care it
I find you got four AIDS you would just
pay somebody so your philosophy was like
hey I'm gonna go get AIDS but I have a
lot of money so just take care of Tommy
there's no people with AIDS the only no
magic Johnson beat AIDS and he's wealthy
never had AIDS he an HIV well you know
what I'm saying they can't find it in
him anymore he beat it yeah but there's
other people so wait a minute the only
reason that you the reason that you
don't sleep with tons of people is just
cuz you're not rich I think that wealth
wealth allows you to be above society in
many regards yeah you don't have to be
nice to people you don't have to
cultivate a person
ality yeah and you certainly don't have
to find a way to make a living yeah and
those those are my natural antisocial
tendencies money would allow me to be
the antisocial person they secretly want
to be who sleeps with just to make you
upset I don't think you would make me
anymore from I think you'd be a complete
prostitute if you wrote like that now I
know you have horse tendencies no I have
dormant whorish tendencies that I don't
act upon because I'm too afraid right
but if you had that money with the whole
continent yep well we've really been
going a while here you know we should do
we should we should bring this back with
pink thankful for being born where and
the good old US of A yes Christmas we're
also gonna pick up we're gonna pick this
up next week we're gonna we're not gonna
disclose the location but we're gonna be
in South Florida and we're going to do a
podcast where hopefully we can get some
guests some guest appearances maybe from
some aunts some uncles some parents
siblings cousins
yeah I'm hopeful we can do a mega mommy
Christmas podcast that's what I'm most
excited about and if this makes it up in
time which I hope it will you can also
look forward to seeing me Tom Segura New
Year's Eve in the city of Livonia I
believe which is on the outskirts or
it's a suburb of Detroit at Joey's two
shows New Year's Eve is Joey's Joey's
yeah you know what that might be the
best name for a comedy club because it's
not trying to be creative it's better
than flappers it's not flappers or dr.
grande yes
Joey's you know what I'm thankful I'm
thankful for fucking Joey's right now so
my and you're gonna be somewhere where
you're gonna be anything beyond San
Francisco the Palace of Fine Arts with a
bunch of other comics it's not just me
it's like Nick Thune
and Laurie Coe Martin sounds like he's
gonna line up some other people oh and
here's something I'll try to output I
already retweeted it today but I saw
that I saw on Tom Pappas Twitter line he
tweeted that there's a big greg Giraldo
benefit for his family that they're
doing a show it's going to be like Jerry
Seinfeld Papa David tell Jim Norton like
all the heavy hitters and it's all going
to greg draw those families so in new
york i don't know what date but i've
retweeted it and you can follow me at
Tom Segura you can follow Christina at
Christina P so anyways I thought that
was really cool so if you're in New York
you get a chance that sounds like an
awesome show and so we'll pick up next
week from your mom's house thanks for
tuning in I love you have a great
Christmas everybody we're gonna talk to
them before Chris we are yeah okay we'll
have fun Christmas shopping yeah eat a
lot